we understand that you just wrote an
article for filmmaker magazine like a
four-page spray can you tell us how that
came about and what you felt you needed
to tell the audience okay well the the
way the filmmaker article came about was
i'm working with a really good PR team
so that's that's I think that's another
advice that I'd like to give to people
out there who are not that I'm in any
position to give advice let me just let
me just say that first but if if I if I
could give advice what I would say is
that when you're doing a film and you're
financing a film make sure on the tail
end you have people who will work with
you in public relations because you know
you can make a film but it's useless
unless people know about it unless
people actually see it so so i'm working
with a really great team and one of the
guys christopher kaplan on the team
orchestrated that event and and he
pitched the film which the magazine's
the magazine found the film interesting
and they found i guess i guess they
found my story interesting so therefore
they contacted us to write an article
about how we how we produce two films so
the guidance i got from the editor of
the magazine was basically they wanted
to know really the nuts and bolts of it
not so much the creative process but how
did you get to the Black Russian how did
you get the funding for it and basically
we got the funding from the Black
Russian was from the profits we made for
mockery decision which was the first
note so in that four page article we
describe how the impetus for awkward
decision came about how we got financers
for that movie and how we made a profit
from the first movie paid back the
financers in kind who were very thrilled
with us and we had enough funds left to
shoot the Black Russian have money left
over for PR and start pre-production for
winters dream which is what we're
working on right now
so so oh I mean I like all I can really
say is you know fundamentally the
article if I could you know sum it up in
a nutshell is we got lucky with the
first film we just did you know there's
no way around it that's the way I view
it people may view it differently but I
view it I got very lucky I found a niche
audience that seemed to like the film we
we did very well in our foreign sales
and we got funds and we move forward
you